our next guest is a teacher in
philadelphia who goes above and beyond
for his students with a very unique
approach to learning and that is why he
is today's drew gooder
hi my name is carlos saponte i am the
founder and executive director of we
love philly we love philly does its best
to turn the community the city of
philadelphia into the classroom for high
school aged youth i got fed up with
trying to teach the regular curriculum
to the students growing up as a post
2000 baby like a lot of these students
are they're constantly on their cell
phones they're constantly interacting
with media and the traditional classroom
setting is no longer a place where most
students feel stimulated
i decided to take students out of the
classroom to give them that real world
experience and try to peel their faces
away from themselves for a little bit
students have gone and volunteered at
over 50 non-profit organizations we
cleaned our community for 12 straight
hours and we raised 10 thousand dollars
for a school bus that students use as a
mobile education vehicle we're literally
creating the education that our youth
want so taking their voices listening to
them
co-collaborating with them watching them
grow and take ownership there's really
no place that i'd rather be
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming on i think
not only in the pandemic when people
were doing schools out in the woods and
yeah and home school and all the rule
books got lit on fire and thrown out the
window
where did you get the idea to sort of
shift the teaching style that would
really speak to these modern kids
i got the idea from looking within
myself to find
where i needed to grow as an individual
and i wanted to get more involved in my
community and i wanted to students to
see that the community was a place where
there's tons of opportunities and tons
of love so i used to go around
volunteering videotaping it and then i
used to bring it into the classroom to
show the students all the possibilities
that were out there that got them
curious and then we just started
developing curriculum to get them into
the community and on the streets where
does your teaching passion come from
it comes from growing up in the city of
philadelphia and just wanting that male
mentor that family sort of lifestyle i
had a rough upbringing um i'm my
family's great now we've all come
together and we've all forgiven and and
we love each other but just growing up
and not feeling like you had somebody to
to share your experiences with or to ask
questions too that inspired me to get
into teaching and then just working with
the student population that has a very
similar upbringing just the city of
philadelphia in general has a very
similar story and just to be that person
that i always wanted wanted as a as a
child just that's where my passion comes
from that is so powerful you know and
this these times are so unprecedented
kids are learning such different ways
now how has we love philly your group
how has it changed the students views
towards learning
oh it it brings it to their actual it
makes it real for them um so example
right now we're taking a shipping
container we're turning it into a tiny
home with the intention for the students
to sell it so and keep the money for it
oh it teaches them so much right yes
it's us working together what would you
like to do now let me co-create and
provide you the resources in order for
your for you to create what you want in
this reality and that's where the boss
came from that's where the shipping came
container came from it all came from
students brains and i just provided the
resources and the and the quitter
backing in order to help them create it
we just love everything that you're
doing and we're not the only ones by the
way gateway wants to give you ten
thousand dollars
continue all the good work that you are
doing thank you so much
[Applause]
and guess what that is not all they're
going to give you 10 laptop computers
for the students to further their
education as
oh my well thank you so much guys i
appreciate you all
it's it's yeah i'm i'm speechless thank
you gateway thank you ross thank you
drew all the beautiful people i've
interacted with just getting on this
show i appreciate all of you
well we appreciate it we appreciate you
and we love you and we love your story
and people need to see it and be
inspired
and
try different approaches
let's not stay stuck and you're an
inspiration to me with that thank you
thank you
[Music]